computer vision is a relatively a new
technology
and
it's hard and it takes a long time to
develop and bring it to a level
where you can put it in shoppers hands
and so this is one
but on the other hand you don't want to
take five years of the development now
to bring something to market so
this is also something
you know identifying what is the minimal
version the mvp that you really need
to define and then go for this
and on later on add more capabilities
and we always try and
you know
think that way
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm going to be speaking
to raz golan the co-founder and ceo of
shopik
a veteran of the 8200 unit of the
israeli intelligence corps raz is a
seasoned product leader with over a
decade of experience in research product
management intelligence and r d
prior to his army service raz started a
bachelor's degree in the age of 14
during high school and co-founded
sikumuna.co.i.m
israel's largest studying materials
website
after completing the army service raz
has joined checkpoint as a security
researcher then joined semantics i
started developing nlp algorithms
founding team as a vp product
raz golan welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today thank you michael i'm
good thank you for having me it's good
to be here thank you thank you for
having me uh i love going to the
supermarket i love the experience i hate
the the checkout and the whole card
thing it's it's always such a hassle but
walking around and the actual experience
is great and i want to retain that
experience in the next few years and i
and i don't want to shop for groceries
online and so hopefully you'll help me
do that with shopik
tell me a little bit about yourself and
and how you end up working on the next
generation of the shopping cart
um well it's quite uh an interesting
story uh originally i don't come from
the retail industry at all and i by the
way really hate going to the supermarket
uh the way it is today um and uh we're
trying to solve that
but uh originally i come from the cyber
security space this is where i met my
co-founder iran kravitz
and uh a few years after the army we
reconnected and they wanted to start a
business together this was our dream for
for many many years um but we wanted to
be creative and not do it in the cyber
space uh where our friends went to um
and he we did uh
some uh systematical uh
process of going through different
markets and exploring different problems
that we think that are worth solving uh
and we ended up looking at the retail
space the physical retail space and we
said wow we stopped immediately and we
really wondered how it haven't changed
dramatically in about a hundred years
more or less with some um a few upgrades
in the middle um and we really wanted to
change things there we thought that
technology is here and the retailers are
ready shoppers are obviously ready for
better technologies and better
shopping journeys in those physical
stores
and we took this challenge
so you know you have to go pretty much
the entire spectrum in order to go from
cyber and internet cyber all the way to
retail experience and so obviously
you've had quite an interesting journey
on the ideation phase so tell me a
little bit about the systematic approach
that you went through and and and sort
of what were the questions that led you
towards you know figuring out that you
know the retail space has enough
capacity for innovation in the in the
grand impact that you want to bring to
it yeah so um we looked uh first on from
the problem perspective uh where do we
see really really big problems that
cause
um a big loss
or that customers are willing to pay a
lot of money to solve them
then
once we you know map these problems that
we personally feel a connection to uh we
started mapping the market seeing who
are the big players
are there any uh existing solutions
trying to solve the same problem or uh
is it uh you know a new market that
we're trying to create and then you know
going down into more and more details uh
then obviously we got out of the
building and started talking to relevant
players
potential customers
companies that tried and looked at the
market
investors who were friends
and you know after doing all these
conversations and drilling down we
started to get a pretty good image if in
certain markets for example the
technology uh the technology was the
barrier or in certain markets uh the
business wasn't or the opportunity
wasn't big enough
um and this is how we narrowed down
then got to to physical retail where all
the parameters
were right
the market is huge the technology is
mature
uh the customers are willing to pay a
lot of money to change what they have
today
and recently by the way uh throughout
this journey uh some really interesting
things happen like uh amazon going from
online to offline with a lot of force
opening stores both small and medium and
showing us what uh you know amazing
technology and a lot of uh um you know
fast development can do
um so it's only increased the level of
interest and
the the movement of the market
you know i actually did a a class at
stanford on on product management with
target uh that we were working with the
target the company looking at innovation
and retail and it was fascinating to
work with uh somebody some of the
executive team they were thinking
through and then understanding you know
what the efforts that walmart is take is
undertaking
to really rethink the shoppers
experience in retail and obviously this
is all in the backlight of of amazon
purchasing whole foods and and you know
you can only imagine what's happening to
the world if you had to distill
the the pain that you're that you're
observing and that you're really
focusing on in just a few sentences what
did you and iran you know really set out
to do with shopik
initially we wanted to solve the problem
of checkout lines
but today we look at the entire shopping
experience
as the the thing we want to improve
and basically
merging
the online experience in offline stores
with the offline experience so creating
this new hybrid experience
is what we are creating and it solves
actually many many problems so it
solves the problem of queues at checkout
it avoids
customers abandoning their
you know carts and walking out the store
it helps retailers
get customers who wouldn't have come to
the store in the first place because
they know how bad the experience is it
increases the basket size of those
customers
the benefits are just huge
so
tell me you know the
new way the consumers are interacting
with their shopping
routine
now that now that they're using a
supermarket that has shopping integrated
with them how does the consumer journey
look from the consumer side
yeah so so so the experience is is
really
what it's called frictionless shopping
so you would enter the store
and then you get our device
you mount it on your shopping cart
simple click
and then using cameras and really
powerful processors that we have on the
device we use computer vision to
automatically detect everything that's
going in or out of the cart uh you bag
items as you shop we interact with you
with offers and coupons and you see the
full
uh basket as you shop with full
transparency
it can go all the way to
you know personalized offers based on
your shopping history and contextualized
offers based on your location in store
and what shelf you stand next to
it's really endless and just like we
would get in an online website
uh then when you're ready to pay and
leave the store you pay on the device
with either credit card or digital
wallet return it before you leave the
store and exit all of our items are
bagged in the cart use the same card to
exit
um and that's it that easy
if you had to
pinpoint some of the aha moments that
a customer like myself that you know i
would go into for the first time using
topic what are some of those specific
moments in the in the store in the
supermarket that i would just stand
there and say like what the hell is
happening here yeah yeah so um i can
tell you that the moments we liked the
most uh in our live deployments when we
saw you know real shoppers interacting
with the system
um the most distinctive one is
when they enter the first item to the
cart and it's automatically recognized
um
usually it's uh the reaction is wow it
looks like magic
how it is this working
um
because most customers are used to uh
scan barcodes and we are not reading the
barcodes we look at the item itself so
they are
absolutely amazed by it
and it happens every time
and then
i would say the second moment is a
checkout when they see that they can pay
with a click
two seconds and leave the store it just
feels uh almost too easy at the
beginning
right and so if you're looking now at
where you are in the journey and you
know there's a long road from developing
the technology all the way to you know
educating a marketing shifting consumer
behavior
maybe can you help me pinpoint some of
those key challenges that you foresee
on on you know the journey that that is
a long one
yeah um
i think that um
you know when you begin with a problem
um it's really broad and then you have
to
focus on how you're solving it
what differentiates you from others
and how fast can you move and get it to
market
and
i think that at topic and this is what
really differentiates us
we have built a whole
method and approach that is very
operationally driven
uh we started the company more than six
years ago we are very familiar with with
the retail market
um and i think one of the best examples
is that we have learned how operational
a store is a retail store is
their margins are extremely thin about
1.5 or 2 percent at net margin
and everything is very very well
optimized so
we understood that our approach has to
be around the store we have to build our
solution around the store and not vice
versa
and
basically everything else followed
so
understanding this core
foundation
really helped us to build an entire
platform around it
and you know get it to market and really
explain why we think we do it um
you know unlike any other company in the
sector
how critical here do you think is the
the first to market or the go-to-market
approach in terms of timeliness versus
the intellectual
the intellectual property of the of the
knowledge and and you know the models
that you're training here which one do
you think has a bigger impact on on
whether shopping will succeed or not
i think it's a combination because
computer vision is a relatively a new
technology
and
it's hard and it takes a long time to
develop and bring it to a level
where you can put it in shoppers hands
and so this is one
but on the other hand you don't want to
take five years of the development now
to bring something to market so
uh this is also something um you know
identifying what is the minimal
uh version the mvp that you really need
um to define and then go for this
uh and on later on add more capabilities
and we always try and you know
think that way
is is there some race when you look at
the different players in the world that
are looking at the shopping experience
as to who will create the consumer
behavior that will end up sticking and
or in other words is there is there a
reason to believe that there is going to
be one market leader that is going to
transform the shopping experience or
could there be a fragmentation where
some of the market is using some some
technology and consumer behavior and
another fragmented market is is looking
at another at another use case yeah um
so definitely segmentation uh there's no
one solution that fits all
there are solutions that are much better
for small type of stores like
convenience stores
with a very different type of shopping
journey you go there for one or two
items at night really quick in and out
there are other solutions that are made
for larger stores where you spend 45
minutes to an hour and sometimes we
would even see
different solutions in the same store um
right so
yeah
so and how how old is shopping now
a little over six years
a little over six years and so we're in
we're in march of 2020 and
i remember vividly that stanford shuts
down and i'm exiled from campus and
you know my favorite stores costco
target walmart i'm not even able to
enter them let alone the food aisles of
any of these tours
you know where are you like what do you
what do you do what where do you
go from there
um so yeah that was a special moment for
us first a lot of uncertainty what's
going on in the world but
in you know in parallel to that we've
just uh completed our series a
um we were thinking about how to expand
quickly
and then we started getting calls from
our customers saying how we can expedite
our projects timeline because we want to
get uh your solution to market quicker
because because we cannot handle the
amount of customers getting to the store
so we must have our
experience more efficient this is one i
remember that time the checkout no more
toilet paper yep no more yeah yeah and
also the the distance between shoppers
and the interactions they wanted to be
as independent as possible
so um we tried to help them
and so that actually you know you you
actually had increased demand at that
time because of you know
the the the ripple effect of what was
happening due to the beginning of covet
right yeah yeah luckily the the entire
supermarket industry had uh a good
impact from kovit so yeah luckily we
uh we growed the company and not vice
versa
how do you compare you know on a
personal level your experience working
in retail to your prior experience in
the cyber space i'm coming from the
cyber space as well and so i i i can
imagine how different of an experience
it is you know running a team that is
looking at retail and this physical
device hardware and software with a lot
of you know behavioral economics and
psychology in mind versus looking at the
cyber space which has a bit of a
different
a different intellectual set yeah yeah
um well here uh it's everything
everything surrounds the shopper
uh and the store uh there are the two
most important factors in what we do so
for the shopper we want to deliver the
best shopping experience and the store
we want to provide the most minimal
interaction with the system and
smoothness in deployment and maintenance
so i would say it's
it's very um
user centric
um versus very technologically oriented
uh with cyber you know
your users in cyber are very different
uh but it's not a consumer product that
you're building you're building
technology for you know
the fans or attack or whatever but um
yeah the core is very different
so which which core are you more
attached to on a personal level are you
more attached to you know the
technological core of really
understanding the technology whether it
be computer vision or or you know
vulnerabilities in cyber or is it more
about the consumer behavior and this
complicated supply chain and the
go-to-market strategies where where are
you and you know between these two
worlds so uh it changed uh i'm a
technologist at heart and in my
background so uh the technology has
fascinated me and it will always
fascinate me uh especially this cutting
edge new things that we are building
but on the other hand um you know
building a business
and selling to retailers
is also fascinating and understanding
their business how they operate and what
they look uh look at when you know
evaluating uh our sort of solution is uh
is also you know area of interest for me
i can only imagine the the satisfaction
one may get you know entering a
supermarket and and just looking at the
shopping carts and saying i created this
and this person is having this aha
moment because of something that i
created right
yeah yeah um
exactly and you know in general building
something that you can use at the
supermarket is very nice and easy to
relate to so
also when you talk to friends
um about shopping versus talking about a
cyber project it's much easier
it's much more fun to talk about over a
glass of beer i can completely see that
happening yeah if you if you go back a
little bit you know
pre-army pre-cyber definitely
pre-shopping
you know who i want to get to know who
who roz is you know on a deeper level
and you know what what really fascinated
you as a kid where where did your
curiosity lie
what really you know triggered your mind
as you were approaching the world even
let's say 10 years old
um
i think
i really liked
science so you know all sorts of
experiments and uh
mainly physics and chemistry
um
but also um um coding and technology
like computers and
um so it was all about experimenting in
in new things and learning new
technologies from a very young age
um
also during high school
lots of personal projects with friends
most of my friends had the same you know
areas of interest so we liked working
together
um we even founded
a website to share um study materials
between us that grew and and became very
popular so it was all about creating
solving our problems and hopefully
helping others
uh and enjoying the process
i love it and if you had to think of
you know a few words that if i would ask
iran or any of the supermarkets you're
working with how would they describe
baraz in in a few words what what kind
of words come to mind
um yeah this is a good question
the easiest one of course
i would say uh first um precision
um okay yeah i like to look at the big
picture but sometimes i also really like
the details just a part of my my nature
um
passion i think would be the second
and uh thirdly optimistic as we have to
be as entrepreneurs all the time
i love it
i want to say that i i'm very inspired
by these types of of companies that are
leveraging deep technology for shifting
consumer behavior if i think of the
company that i will want to start one
day and this shopic has a lot of the
elements that i would be looking for as
an entrepreneur and i can very much
relate your own passion and excitement
for taking you know your technological
background but then creating a really
positive impact on on a real problem in
in a world that is constantly changing
that so sort of has endless potential
and and while i think that a lot of
people may intuitively assume that just
everything is shifting online we have to
remember that there are a lot of these
human experiences that we will continue
to have for many many many years and
just because they're in the physical
world doesn't mean that they don't have
technological innovation there as well
and so thank you for spending this time
with me i really appreciate it and best
of luck with shopik and i can't wait to
experience it myself at the supermarket
thank you very much you're most welcome
and uh we can definitely schedule a tour
i'd love that thank you bye-bye thanks
bye-bye